Yes, there's a lot of memes on this channel. (We love your memes)
You laugh You lose, (original content)
it's about memes.
Pew News, (rip Gloria Borger)
it's about reporting on memes.
Meme Review, *clap clap*
reviewing memes.
But the finest
of them all,
the greatest,
the most grandiose
of them all
is the PewDiePie memes everybody.
That's right.
I'm talking of course about
YouTube's
favorite show,
LWIAY!
(accompanied by dramatic music)
(about like zonoon)(idk)
LWIAY intro-
🎶Leave your entries in the subreddit bros and i'll watch submissions in the next episode of LWIAY🎶
Flex tape can't fix his heart
when the real damage is on the inside
Well clearly it takes a lot of effort to get on the PewDiePie sub read everyone so honestly don't even try. (I tried once ):    )
It's impossible, now 'DATS ALOTTA DA-'' I love how this rebound- this flex meme...
rebounded.Everyone was like (mocking 9 year old's voice) 'Ah you're stealing Jontron's video'.
Oh why? Why are some meme bouncing back then if I just stole it? That's right!
You can't steal what other people steal from you-
you can't... (stop stealing!)
Steal. From me. And say. that I'm. S t e a l i n g. (can we copy strike this?)
Disgusting. I'm gonna report it to the meme police *dials 911*
if you guys don't watch out. Pewdiepie giving his last brofist before ending the channel. 20-  how do I even say that?
'two thousand three hundred eighty seven colorized'. More like
2019 polarized, don't worry about it. And yes, I know. I look good as an anime character.
mhAhAhAHaha
See? This is what I'm telling you guys. I've been trying to tell you guys for so long
Yes, my girlfriend is- my fiance? Do I say fiance? My future wife is in fact
italiano. This is how she talks to me everytime.
(bad italian accent imitation in higher voice) Eh Félix
It isa not that are verry goood. You need to get the morre likes on this viideo.
Ask them to liike it right noww and hit the bell buttonn. (end accent)
Will eventually get to that point in a relationship where all she does is this; and I'll know exactly what she's talking about. (relationship goals!!)
Oh, it's one of these. Why am I wearing headphones meme?
'Dan'
'Dancer'
'Can' Then why are you posting here? You can't call something cancer if you are it yourself (yes they can), you can't-cer...
'cAn We CoPyStRiKe tHe GaMeThEoRiStS?!?' 'Yes, pewdiepie our chairs do do that'. I'm not even upset
I'm actually more aroused; very nice. But can you simultaneously
Whip and nae name (STOP) Matt Pat, huh? Answer me that one. Can you do this while simultaneously
Whipping and nae nae? I'll be waiting for your response.
(MatPat: I just simultaneously whipped and naE NAED!!!!!)
Matt Pat is trying to kill the planet.
Everyone knows you can't charge that much energy at once.
''Can someone please make a better version of 'Pewbunga'?"
oH mAh gAh
ohhhuhhh
*Swedish gibberish*
click away
Ahh AHhahAH!
w00of w00of
That was close.
This is why I have my trusty (cocks gun) at hand at all times. If a meme is too powerful...
*pew* (cocks gun)
It needs to be destroyed.
Everyone commentin, so we can trick the YouTube review people that this is a family-friendly video. (Video still gets demonetized) Everyone comment:
'Wow, I really enjoyed watching this video with my son. We had a great time together.
Well, actually we never had this much quality time together. In fact, I do love my son right now.
In fact, I might just love him a little bit too much,'
bRoFiSt, damn (gets demonetized) that looks. Disgusting.
What are you cooking in your pan? Dyou not clean it in between what is all that white stuff, dude? (it's the remains of Swedish boys)
Disappointed, disgusting, repulsive but also 'Brrofiist!' Watching pirated movies be like...
'audio-video. Audio video. Video audio.' What a bad meme!
I-if 2018 memes can be summarized. It has to be with- like...
Just a text over anything. Anything! Just put a text over anything and it's a meme! If YouTube rewind doesn't feature
text layered memes. I just realize that's the way to kill a meme. When was its featured on YouTube rewind
HahAHAHA *CLAP CLAP*
'Is this 15,000 people?'
(mocking high voice) "She was just joking about being oppressed outside. It was just a joke."
Wait for that response, by the way. I'm anticipating it. (imitating Tana mockingly) Guys! Obviously I don't want people to be opressed outside.
I just said it. I had joke because I love being oppressed outside. By the way, 15,000 people showed up. (stops imitating)
(chuckling) 'My name is Connor. Heh, oh god, it's coming back. It's back for vengeance'. Well, I really need to play that game...
But am I gonna!? But iMmA GoNnA? I hope there's some "but am I gonna" memes in there?
That would make me happy.
But then again you guys aren't that creative. 'What if Pewdiepie uploaded an uncut and unedited
version video and there was a contest to see who would come up with the best edit?'
*clap clap*
(chuckling)
Finally! We have figured out a way so I can replace Brad 1 and Brad 2.
(little high pitched laugh)
I don't have to come up with my original content. Great! Now I don't even have to pay my editors anymore. *Brad 1 and Brad 2 are crying*
(laughing) I can just like let my fans do it. This is great. I really like this idea!
(his voice fades) You said it first. Let it be known that you said it first.
Sive was always memeing. (imitates Sive mockingly) 'You need to pay me more oob boo doo boo doo boo dooo'
Oh, yeah?
'When you start bullying children and become leafy in order to avoid'
(barely audible because he's laughing) 'your testicle'
That was a clever meme actually; well done. The joke here is, of course, that I am leafy now.
I mean I do look better. There's no doubt about it. I sort of understand leafy now.
'They've make Jake Pauls roasts into a real thing.'
WAAAAALLLLMMAAAAAARRRT
Is that real? That's awesome.
(voice says the text bubble) Today we're gonna be diving into the future --  (pewds: hey, it's grandayy everybody) -of Fortnite
and see what developers are gonna be working on  for the next few months including yes; dragons in fortnite... (STOP)
(louder deafening music) Let's go, lose control. 3, 2, 1, drop it.
ALI-A intro (earrape = death) (Rip headphone users)
Another one. Damn! See? If I only- if only I invested in this meme stock, I would be a millionaire.
Plus, you know, I could use insider information because surely somehow, or I'm not taking credit okay,
but surely if I review a meme, there should be some killing of that meme so that I can sell off those memes-
Does this make any sense? (no.)
'All women...(light saber opening) are Queens!'
Yess!
(other voice talking) 'If she breathe... (light saber opening) she's a Thot!'
No!
(light saber opening) she's a THOOOAAAOOT!'
(mutters) Jesus Christ
(voice screaming angrily then light sabers touching)
QUEEN
THOOOT
THOOT
QUE E N
T H O T
QUEE N   THO T    Q U E E N   T H O T (EARRAPE)
We didn't need the ear rappé, but very good edit by the way.
A lot of- so-fyou- people do put s-s-so much effort into these dumbass things. That's what makes a meme beautiful.
Well done Joe average 2 2 1...
'Whether she's a queen or a thot, if she had headphones in, she's now deaf .'
Or if she know how to properly structure sentence. (Swedish boi roast)
She wouldn't be parted Jesus Christ. A lot of video memes. I like that.
Keep the video memes coming great job to whoever made this meme
Are these all the memes I reviewed? (tss)
Oh I see (chuckles)
(edna) 'So you don't know where he is...'
'Would you like to find out?'
Is that's supposed to be Mariza? (?)
(gay chuckle)
I'm never doing Pepe.
Pepe needs to live forever. He's far too important
BtHa ha ha ha ha
Oh, come on!- what?- I want- (chuckles loudly)
(more swedish chuckling)
That was- I was getting into it,! Can you make the whole- whole movie please? Just change the whole plot? (very chuckle worthy meme 10/10)
(chuckle)
'Woah, an whole article saying good things about Pewds? That's nice.' I did see that.
Thank you FragHero. Namaste, I think it's the only one that really ahh~
I've seen put ahhm~
Put emphasis on it. I mean, it's like every article ever. They mentioned me and they bring up all my bad past.
But they would never mention any of this. Because it doesn't fit to portray me as a somewhat decent character.
I bet Pewds is gonna love this tattoo
Well, I like Batman so that's cool. Oh, it's an okay sign didn't look. Thank you very much (comment "rip" if you fell for this)
I will pee through it. (wat)
(chuckles)
'Thank you bus driver,very cool!'
'Dr. Phil: I call it contentInator'. Oh, I'm sorry. I made three videos
You're all a bunch of cryyyybabies.
(imitates us whining) Wah, wah, wah, wah
I don't care! (fake menacing sound whilst showing teeths) HuuuuuuUU
(weird intonation) I'm not like those other youtubers who say they love their fans; super lame. I say: screw you fans!
(whispers) please like the video though, thank you (kiss)
'Epic Games thought Pewds was going to play fortnite (get ready cuz he's gonna start talking at god speed)so they made a custom banner for him that only he gets it if he ever plays'
Is that true? Cuz I did play Fortnite once and I thought it was legitimately a fun cool game.
But my own pride came in between that (chuckling) it was so popular. Well, they're doing fine without me
I think they'll be all right. (laughs)
'Aww that's actually kind of nice'. Don't make me feel bad!!
(laughing)
Is it time? It's a time for me to play Fortnite? *does collab w/ Ali-A to get those views*
It's time for me to bite the bullet and bite my pride and my stubbornness-
'Making an hour long video of quality content'
'Making a 10 minute video about important matters'
'Making a 10 minute video about memes'
'Making a 10 minute video about bean memes'
'But get bored in the middle (laughing) and just ask Brad~'
'And Brad 2 to edit the shh out of it and add a minute of beans' (laughing)
'with music and a minute of ASS commercial to get to the 10 minute mark.' (Like if you watched until the end cuz i did :D )
'Felix has really outdone himself this time'. This is not true.
Okay, you guys think you know me just because you presented through a meme?
I mean I could just record an hour-long video quality content.
But am I gOnNA?! I don't think so. I upload every day. I'm sorry-y~
Sometimes I get really busy with other stuff and life comes up or whatever. I have other projects that
I'm working on in the background and sometimes I'm sad to say I don't have that much time to put on a videooo.
Eight years, every single day. Eight years, eight years everybody. I'm sorry. I'm sorry!
Now you (cocks gun) apologize!
Okay? I said sorry; you say sorry.
(loudly) Is this an outro?
Listen, it's a creative way to show the gameplay of Animal Super Squad, A.S.S., the greatest game of all time.
Check it out, link description and enjoy...
(automated women voice) A is for - (pewds voice) Anime
'B is for -' bUT caN yOU Do tHiS??
(laughs)
'C is for -' cOPyStRikE
'D is for -' Deleting my channel
(laughs) 'E is for -' Edgar
'F is for -' family friendly Felix.
That's it!! 'G is for -' GAMEPLAY
'H is for -' hMmMMmMmmmm (laughs)
'I is for -' Intellectual
'J is for - 'Jake Paul
'K is for -' (brad) Kiss me
'L is for -' LWIAY
Is it the whole alphabet?
Whaskey. (he repeats that)
'X is for -' (earrape of pewdiepie ranting about god knows what)
'Y is for -' You laugh you loose
'Zee is for -' zero deaths
YAYYYYYYYYYYY!! (claps thrice)
That's awesome. Thank you boringforest.
'For 9-year-olds'. Oh, that's awesome. Now you guys know! (sarcasm) That is so thoughtful.
What a thoughtful meme everybody; everyone go upvote this.
'When you're so poor in real life that even shadow rendering is set to low.'
When you're so poor in real life that you own an overly expensive laptop everybody.
Wow this meme made so much sense.
Meme correction! (claps twice) Do it right and do it again!
Okay,? Maybe put a bag of Lidl with a shadow on it or something. Jesus Christ y'all dumb... That's it!
My fellow nine-year-olds. That was it. We did it. (clapping)
Thank you guys for all the memes. This is really fun.
I really enjoyed it. If you had fun as well, leaving like and I'll see you guys tomorrow. Goodbye!
[weird hand gestures]